Jake says,
I've been incredibly inspired by you love what you do and would like to
enlighten people in a similar manner.
Be careful what you wish for it is,
is it appropriate to aim to have as much as an impact as you or more so?
Um,
I think it's the idea is formulated wrong in some sense.
Yeah.
I think,
I mean,
it's good to have people that
okay,
you admire,
let's say,
okay,
who can serve as models and I'm not claiming that I'm necessarily in that
category,
but it's good to have people like that.
But what you want to figure out to do two D to do is how to manifest the ideal
within the confines of your own life,
right?
Because you're a particular sort of person.
And so the way that you're going to live your life best,
it's very unlikely that it would be associated in any important way with the way
that I've chosen to live my life unless we have very similar temperaments,
which is possible.
But you know,
relatively unlikely
because the odds against that are,
you know,
extraordinarily high.
Um,
the odds of any two people having the same temperament are very,
are very high.
So what you can do is aim to,
to Orient yourself towards a high good that you can conceive up to discipline
yourself to tell the truth and all of that.
And then what I would say is that as your life unfolds,
you'll have the amount of influence that you should have,
whatever that happens to be.
You know,
some people live pretty local lives.
Like my life for example,
is much more public than my wife's life.
But that doesn't mean that her contribution is somehow lesser.
I mean she's been unbelievably good with our kids.
My daughter was very ill and my wife was extraordinarily good with her and was a
great mother and it's been a tremendous help to me as a very honest person and a
wise person.
And you know,
that all has an impact.
It's just not as obvious because while the kids really love her and now she's
got grandkids and God only knows what the consequence of that is going to be
across successive generations,
and you know,
she isn't interested in the public life.
I'm a journalist of hours to interviewer quite recently about what the last
year's been liking her preferences to not do that.
And that's fine.
Like she has her own destiny and her own way of being in the world.
And there's nothing to say that it's lesser in any sense of the word at all.